[Music]
hey guys it's katie and i'm here with my
husband chris hello we're back in the
kitchen today to make some more drinks
from starbucks but these are all special
like viral tick tock drinks like custom
starbucks young people drinks yeah there
are two reasons i'm doing this at home
one i don't love to order super
complicated drinks at starbucks i used
to work at starbucks and those would
give me a nightmare the second reason is
you just may not want to spend five to
six dollars on one of these large drinks
you don't want to spend that kind of
scratch that kind of dough what is
happening all right well i'm gonna get
started i'm excited get out of here i
will hopefully these drinks will be a
star
let's do it freeze frame the first drink
i'm gonna make is called the prettiest
drink at starbucks and it is really
beautiful it's this ombre pink and
yellow drink it basically looks like a
sunset and it's the strawberry acai
refresher with raspberry and lemonade so
you'll take a large glass and you'll
fill it up with ice next i have some
lemonade so i'm not going to add
raspberry syrup i'm going to add
raspberry extract i'm doing this because
it's clear and also i don't want to add
any more sugar this is pretty sweet
lemonade we're going to pull back on the
sweetness and the next thing i have is
my strawberry acai base am i saying acai
right i'm sorry if i'm not is it
for this i combined strawberry powder
with acai powder and a little bit of
water put that in the microwave until it
dissolved and to that i added white
grape juice water cashew puree green tea
and some simple syrup you can put in an
airtight container put in your fridge
and store up to five days and if you
guys don't know where to get the powders
you can get them online and i will leave
links in the youtube description so you
can find them to get this ombre i'm
afraid if i just pour it right on top it
will sink to the bottom so i'm going to
do a little trick with a spoon here and
just go
really slow with this i don't know how
they do it at starbucks i think they
just shake it and then
it works but this is the way i figured
it out and you want to put the spoon
right up against the glass oh yeah oh it
looks so pretty it looks like the sunset
i think it looks pretty close to the one
they have at starbucks let's get chris
in here to try it chris all right chris
this is the prettiest drink at starbucks
do you want to do the honors and swirl
it all around i would love to do the
honors let's try this
that's really good it tastes like a
jolly rancher it's like a jolly rancher
lemonade i would be very excited to have
that just all the time well you can take
this because i got seven more drinks
whoa
this next drink i am super excited about
it is an iced white mocha with salted
cream cold foam and caramel on top so
normally when you order the iced white
you don't get salted cold foam so that's
what you have to ask a special for and
then you add more sweetness with that
caramel so the first thing we're gonna
make is the salted cream cold foam we'll
combine heavy cream whole milk sugar and
some salt just a pinch we're gonna mix
that together with a spoon and then
we'll take an immersion blender and it's
gonna get a little messy
just let it do its thing and you'll keep
doing this until you get a nice silky
smooth foam
all right that looks nice and foamy now
that our cold foam is done it's time to
assemble our drink if you ask for extra
caramel they'll take it and they'll
drizzle it all over the sides awesome
we've got the caramel in now we're gonna
do some white mocha syrup which is
incredibly expensive to buy online so i
made my own and what i did is i combined
condensed milk whole milk some vanilla
sugar i put that in a medium saucepan i
brought that to a simmer until the sugar
dissolved then i added white chocolate
chips waited till that melted and at the
very end i whisked in some instant
coffee and then removed it from the heat
so now that's in i'm gonna add in our
hot espresso i just pulled two shots of
espresso this is really taking me back
to when i worked at starbucks because i
worked at a 24-hour one and i remember
when i first started they were like
trying to they gave me all these
espresso shots to keep me awake my
friends and i ended up having to go home
early because i felt so sick to my
stomach don't drink too many espresso
shots kids we're gonna add in some whole
milk and then we will do our ice we want
to leave some room for our cold foam we
will then pour our cold foam in that
looks so good top it off with a little
bit of caramel on the very top yes oh my
gosh this looks good i can't wait to
share this one with chris chris
whoa
wow
wow that's really good that's like a
dessert i'm not taking credit for this
well whoever thought of this you're a
genius this is so good yeah whoever came
up with this knew how to make a perfect
dessert
coffee drink it's amazing it's perfect
the next drink we're gonna do is called
the gummy bear what this basically is is
it's a strawberry acai refresher with
raspberry syrup and peach juice no water
it's a pretty simple drink we're gonna
be working in a shaker like a cocktail
shaker if you don't have a cocktail
shaker you can get a jar like a mason
jar a big one put a cap on it shake it
in there we're gonna add a cup of that
strawberry acai base that we made and
then i'm gonna add three fourths of a
cup peach juice i don't think my shaker
is big enough so i have a bigger shaker
my shaker wasn't big enough i got a
bigger shaker i'm gonna move this
luckily i have lots of cocktail shakers
in my house because i love a cocktail
i'm going to add a tablespoon of
raspberry syrup and then i'm going to
add a cup of ice i feel like a bartender
right now
and [ __ ]
all right now it's time for a drink and
then we'll add some freezer dried
strawberries and there we've got the
gummy bear chris you want to have some
gummy bears so we've got the gummy bear
for you to try
oh
that's good i don't think it tastes like
gummy bears i don't think it tastes like
gummy bears either but it is tasty i
want to keep this one so the next drink
we're gonna make is the pink drink with
matcha vanilla cold foam you can get the
pink drink at starbucks which is
strawberry
acai refresher mixed in with coconut
milk but then you're going to ask for
cold foam with matcha in it and vanilla
if you don't want to ask for that let's
make it at home first i'm going to do is
make that cold foam so kind of the same
thing we did for our salted cream cold
foam we're gonna do whole milk heavy
cream sugar vanilla extract just a
little bit and some matcha powder
when i worked at starbucks i always
ordered the green tea latte that was
like what i i absolutely loved it there
we go look at that foamy
matcha enos our cold foam is done so now
we're just gonna add some more
strawberry refresher that we made
earlier and then some coconut milk i'm
using some from a can and let's give
that a nice stir so they get
incorporated
some freezer dried strawberries after
that oh these are going to get
rehydrated inside we're gonna add some
ice
and now for the foam that is a beautiful
drink chris
it's really um
it's like rich almost but not sweet it's
very earthy i think with the coconut
milk and the matcha is very earthy i
like it i don't love it we are moving on
to blended drinks and i just love a
frappuccino it's basically a milkshake
with ice this first one is called a
strawberry cheesecake frappuccino and i
really hope it tastes like cheesecake i
think it's basically like strawberries
and cream but then they've added a few
other syrups to alter the flavor so
first we'll add some white mocha syrup
this is the same syrup i used on my iced
white mocha then we'll add some cinnamon
dolce syrup again you can buy this one
online as well but it's also harder to
find and pretty expensive so what i did
is i combined granulated sugar brown
sugar water and some vanilla extract i
brought that up to a simmer on medium
heat until all of the sugar dissolved
and then i added some of my cinnamon
cooked that for a little bit longer so
thickened up slightly and then remove it
from the heat and that's it that's all i
had to do making simple syrups at home
is actually pretty easy and it can save
you a lot of money next we're going to
add some vanilla extract strawberry
puree and i also made this strawberry
puree at home all i did was cut up about
two cups of strawberries added a
tablespoon of sugar put it through the
blender and you can store this in an
airtight container in your fridge for up
to five days then we'll add our whole
milk and then we're gonna do a cup and a
half of ice set this guy up on our
blender and pick it up
i forgot to add simple syrup so we're
also just going to add two tablespoons
of simple syrup this is a sweet drink
one more time
all right i think we're good to plate or
what would you to
to glass it what's the drink version of
plating we're going to add some
strawberry puree along the sides then
i'm going to pour
oh or frappuccino here and then you
gotta top it with some whipped cream
we're going more puree on the top we're
back at it with the freezer dried
strawberries crumbs this is a strawberry
cheesecake frappuccino uh let's give it
a try wow
wow that's really really really tasty
okay i don't know if i'm getting
cheesecake i'd say it's as close as you
can get without just grinding cheesecake
into a drink guys i'm having sugar
overload all right so we're gonna keep
this blending train moving and make a
mango dragon fruit refresher lemonade
blended that's a lot so i think normally
you can order a mango dragon fruit
refresher then you could instead of
water do lemonade and then you could
also get it blended instead of just
shaking with ice first what we're gonna
do we'll add some green tea because a
little bit of caffeine not a whole lot
some lemonade grape juice that's
basically white grape juice is what they
use in all the refreshers some fresh
strawberries sliced frozen mango then
some dragon fruit powder and because
this is starbucks we're gonna do some
simple syrup finally we'll add a cup and
a half of ice
put a cap on and here we go
all right oh i cannot
i'm just like loving this color this one
i think is gonna be refreshing okay and
then we're gonna add at the very end
some whipped cream
chris are you ready to be refreshed
beyond
compare let's drink and i'm not talking
booze
wow it's just very fruity it's really
refreshing it's really refreshing that's
a good summertime drink
you know where it just takes me like on
a cruise
yeah i could be on a boat with that but
definitely i'm on a boat drink there's
only one more drink to go it's pretty
epic are you guys ready let's just say
it's a candy themed frappuccino wait
what
okay we're on the last one this is the
twix frappuccino it sounds delicious
it's kind of like a java chip mixed with
a caramel frappuccino you need lots of
different syrups first we're going to
just put in some simple syrup some
toffee syrup some caramel syrup some
hazelnut syrup some espresso some whole
milk java chips which are just chocolate
chips then
and now it's time to blend oh oh i
almost forgot they also just you know
for kicks add some whipped cream just
for fun i don't know can't forget that
this looks good most of this video is
like a montage of me cleaning glasses
cut two 80s themed montage of me
cleaning glasses
[Music]
so we've got it all mixed now for our
glass we're gonna do some caramel
because you gotta but it doesn't stop
there we're also gonna add some
chocolate now time for our frappuccino
oh for the very top you gotta have
whipped cream you've come all this way
we're not saying no to whipped cream a
little bit of
caramel on the top of that and a little
bit of chocolate oh my gosh and that
ladies and gentlemen is a twix
frappuccino according to tick tock and
by me you're gonna love this one it's
the twix frappuccino chris oh my god
[Music]
wow wow wow wow wow wow wow that is
raise the roof raise the roof
that is really tasty okay that tastes
like if twix and coffee had a baby
that's right whoever invented this is a
genius sweets genius everyone loves your
songs if you had to make a song about
the ice white vocal how would it go it's
an ice white mocha for you and me
wow we're on the sugar i don't have any
songs oh that was really fun i'm sorry i
didn't help um
it was sort of fun for me i broke a
glass today that's okay well thank you
guys for watching let us know if there's
any other things you want us to recreate
or any starbucks drinks i didn't try
today but let me know if you try them
typically and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you